Just in to CNN.
Former President
Trump has no plans to testify
before a New York grand jury
investigating those alleged
hush money payments to Stormy Daniels.
Trump's attorney claims
if Trump did, in fact, authorize
the payment to Daniels,
he did so as a victim of extortion.
The DEA had invited Trump
to testify as required
under New York law.
Trump's former fixer and lawyer,
Michael Cohen,
he is expected to provide
additional testimony today.
Well, as Manhattan prosecutors
weigh whether to charge
former President Trump,
he is making his way back
to Iowa tonight,
his first time in the state
since launching his third bid
for the White House.
Despite his legal
troubles, many Iowa
voters tell us
they are still with Trump but
the same may not be true
for some of his former campaign officials
and White House advisers.
CNN's Alina TREENE
joins us now
this morning with her
appointing Elena
What are you hearing from
those in Trump's inner circle?
I mean, we have seen some
who are in the inner
circle publicly break with him, though,
limited number.
You're hearing more in private
I am, Jim and Erica.
I reached out to nine former Trump
campaign officials
who are with him from 2016
throughout his presidency
and only three of them
are publicly willing
to say
that they support Donald Trump's
third White House bid.
Another three said
that they wanted to remain neutral
during the primary
and the other three
refused to weigh in for the story
or do not respond to
requests for comment.
And I'll just add,
I think one of the most
interesting things
that I picked up through
the course of my reporting
is about former
Trump 2016 campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski.
Lewandowski remained very close
within Donald Trump's inner circle
throughout his time in office.
But I'm told that he's recently
been privately reaching out
to Republican operatives
and donors,
telling them not to support
Donald Trump for 20, 24
and also pitching himself to potential
other presidential campaigns,
including that of Governor Ron
DeSantis and Governor Christie.
Now, Lewandowski
denied that reporting to CNN,
but I spoke with more than a dozen
of people
within Trump's orbit who have noted
that Corey has been distancing himself
from Donald Trump
since the 2020 election.
We also gave him an opportunity
to reach out
and endorse
Donald Trump within the story,
but he refused to do so. Well,
interesting.
Elaine, great reporting.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Joining us now to discuss Trump's visit
to Iowa
tonight, editor
in chief of the Iowa Capital
Dispatch, Kathie Obradovich.
Kathie, good to have you with us.
This morning.
If we look at that
reporting from Elaina
in terms of those former
Trump campaign officials,
the split that we're seeing there.
What's also interesting
and you know this better than anyone, is
when we look at
what the interaction is
with local officials,
with elected officials in the state,
the fact that the governor
was with
Governor DeSantis in Iowa
at two different events, that he was also
meeting with lawmakers in the state.
We have reporting
that Trump is making
some of those calls privately
but is there a sense
this morning of where
support stands among Iowa lawmakers
Yeah, I wouldn't read too
much, Erica, into the fact
that Governor Reynolds,
Governor Kim
Reynolds was appearing with this matter.
She's appearing
with every presidential candidate
that comes to town
She had events with Nikki
Haley last month,
just appeared with Tim Scott.
She will.
She has appeared
and I believe she is planning
to appear with Donald Trump.
So she's going to be neutral.
But when we talk to Republicans
at these events
and it's been a busy four day
weekend for the Iowa caucus campaign,
people are not sold on Donald Trump
for 20, 24.
They are still he's still very popular
and he is pulling you know pretty well.
But his polling is down
from what it was a year ago.
And Ron DeSantis
is looking
like the person
that Iowa Republicans are kind of eyeing
to see
if he can be a substitute
or an alternative candidate.
Kathy, Iowa voters,
as you know better than me,
you know,
they're known as
being more knowledgeable.
The the process encourages
engagement with voters
as opposed to
just being kind of a straight up
straw poll.
And I wonder, given your experience
covering so many of these, is Iowa
a place that has a potential
to stray from Trump? Right.
To to give another candidate
an opportunity,
particularly even one,
not just a DeSantis candidacy,
but but someone from
kind of
the more mainstream
or moderate Republican
strain of the party
like Nikki Haley or folks
who are now positioning themselves
in that lane
Iowa is definitely a place, Jim.
And you're right
that new candidates can audition.
You know, they can come.
They don't have to be the most well-known
or the party establishment favorite.
And they can come and get
because it's a cheap market.
You don't have to buy
a lot of advertising.
You can meet people one on one
and get your message out
But the Iowa caucuses
are also not the place
for moderates necessarily,
because it requires this engagement.
You get the activists and the activists
tend to be in the Republican Party
from the more conservative wing.
So, you know, it's
because they have challengers
running to the right of a lot of times
what we would see in past cycles
that, you know,
the Jeb Bush's or
other establishment candidates,
that's where those insurgencies do
very well.
Here
we are in the early days,
obviously, as we know.
But I'm just I'm curious,
as you look at this,
as Iowa once again becomes the center.
Does anything feel different
this time around or heading into 20, 24
Yeah.
Well, first of all,
the Democrats are not,
you know, joining them
joining in on this cycle
because the Democratic National Committee
blacklisted in Iowa So normally,
you know,
this would be
a busier cycle with both parties in play.
Also, I think,
you know, it's interesting to me
how unified the candidates
messages are so far.
A lot of candidates coming to Iowa
talking about education
and especially kind of the culture wars
and education.
That is what Ron DeSantis talked about.
That's what
Nikki Haley spoke about on her
first trip to Iowa.
I believe Donald Trump
will be talking about
education again tonight. As well.
It's partly I think they might think
Iowa Republicans want to hear
that's what
our legislators spent
the entire year talking about so far.
So we'll see what happens.
Kathy, so quickly here, can I ask you,
is the discussion
of a possible indictment in New York
at all,
a topic of discussion there
and does that, in your view, help or hurt
a Trump candidacy in Iowa?
I don't think it
matters to the electorate
for the caucuses.
A lot of those types of things are,
you know, they attribute it to the media
or to partizans in the judiciary or the,
you know, those kinds of things.
I don't see
them as taking that terribly seriously.
But there is a feeling among Republicans
that Trump has too much baggage.
And so,
you know,
this could be just a little part
of what they consider
to be baggage for him.
Kathie Obradovich, thanks so much.